so this is not the first time we've seen
a story like this far from it but
reading now from the daily wire report a
few days ago it says on Monday when
Connecticut had its State Open Track and
Field Championships at Willowbrook Park
one person broke the state open records
for girls in both the 100 and 200 meter
runs that person was you guessed it
twist ending a biological boy Terry
Miller a transgender won the events in
the 100-meter dash the runner up was
Andreea Yearwood who's also a boy
Yearwood won the Class M sprint titles
last year so you may remember hearing
about this guy last year and Miller
competed not now listen so your your
wood was on the girl was competing
against the girls last year Miller who
broke the record he competed on the boys
team during the winter indoor season and
then joined the girls for outdoor so he
was a boy three months ago he was a boy
just a few months ago he was a boy and
now he decided that he's a girl what
happened that caused this revelation
where he suddenly realized oh you know
what um yeah I think I'm a girl you know
I thought I think that's actually what's
happening here I'm a girl yeah okay what
happened like that caused this
revelation on his part well I I think I
might have an answer to that but we'll
get to in a second so
karissa neehoff who's the CIA C
executive she was asked about you know
what about all the girls who were
deprived of a chance to compete because
they were knocked out by these two boys
ants Chrissa says we do feel for them we
fully agree it doesn't feel good the
optic isn't good but we really do have
to look at the bigger issues that speak
to civil rights and the fact that this
is high school sports Hill House coach
Gary Moore said said that the situation
wasn't fair to the girls although he
thinks that Miller the boys should have
been able to compete
so this is this is the kind of moral
courage that we're dealing with here
is he says yeah it's not fair to the
girls but but yeah I mean of course the
boy should be able to compete I mean I'm
not saying yeah I'm just pointing out
and it's not
I mean don't look don't get mad at me
don't hit me please don't hit me don't
hit me no no yes yes it's okay this is
okay I'm just saying that maybe it's a
little bit unfair I don't know don't
yell at me okay fine it's fair it's
actually fair nevermind forget I said
anything
and then it goes on from there with some
quoting some other some other other
people as well
now this guy by the way Miller he won
the 100-meter and he set a record with a
time of 11 72
which is a which is a good time for
girls but he's not a girl just for
comparison's sake
and so that you understand in the state
outdoor track and field championships
for boys
his 1172 would not have even placed okay
so if you're wondering why this guy
Miller decided after competing against
the boys in the indoor competition why
he decided that all of a sudden he's a
girl now well III think this might have
something to do he broke a record
against the girls if he'd raced against
the men if he'd racing in cement he
would have come in 20th place so it's
its first place record breaker on one
hand or 20th place non-qualifying on the
other
he chose the latter
I wonder why
now
this is obviously madness this is total
madness and to think that we treat the
use of steroids as some kind of
unforgivable sin in sports yet we allow
men with their testosterone and their
muscular you know and and and their
advantages with their muscular structure
skeletal structure and so on we allowed
them to compete against girls I mean
it's it's just crazy
it's it's unfair to have people using
steroids and competing but that is quite
a bit more fair than to have boys
competing against girls
at least if you're competing if you're a
girl competing against another girl on
steroids I mean you could use Terrence
too I guess
so that that possibility is open to you
although I don't recommend it but if
you're competing against boys there's
nothing you can do you can't even cheat
to beat him it's just he's gonna beat
you there's nothing you can do
especially when it comes to something
like track and field when it comes to
something like racing because there's
nothing else involved in racing other
than just who's stronger and faster
that's all that matters
there's no extra bit of athleticism and
it by the way I ran track in high school
so I say this with all due respect to uh
to Track & Field this is one of the
things I liked about track and field is
that it's just it's what I liked about
running what I still like about running
is that it's just so kind of direct it's
a very kind of raw and direct sport
where I can I get there faster than you
that's all so if you're a girl competing
against a boy you just you've got no
chance he's got he he's coming with
physical equipment that you just don't
have and so it's wrong and it's unfair
here's the thing I can't really explain
why biological boys shouldn't compete
against girls I can't really explain why
it's wrong to steal these championships
from girls who've been working so hard
for them I can't really explain
it's it's not self-evident to you then
there's not much I can do or say see the
left with its with with this gender
identity nonsense the left has come up
with a position that is so wrong and so
irrational
that in a weird way it's impenetrable it
is a bulletproof argument because it's
so wrong and so crazy that there's
nothing you can say to it it's a
position that can't be defeated because
it's already detached from reality and
so anything that you any argument that
you make is going to be based in reality
so you're making arguments that are
grounded in reality and they're floating
out there in the ether in fantasy world
well what can you can't there's nothing
what are you gonna do so so I can make
my point
that biological boy shouldn't race
against girls
and then you can say well why not
I can say because they're boys that's
why
and if that's not enough for you well I
got nothing
I got nothing else that's it I just you
shouldn't do that we shouldn't do that
because it's it's there boy that's a boy
that's a girl
they shouldn't race against each other
is that is that not clear enough for you
you do you need more than that
that that is the end of the argument
because that's the whole reason I and if
you won't accept that then there's
nothing more to be said
you see traditionally there's a reason
you may be wondering why arguments and
debates in our society are so fruitless
and nobody ever wins an argument no
debate ever goes anywhere and it's
because I think we've we lot we've lost
sight of the point of an argument and a
point of a debate
and there are people who say well you
can never win an argument you know
arguments can never be what well they
can be won the problem arises when one
of the people involved in the argument
won't acknowledge the fact that the
argument has been won
so traditionally you win an argument by
forcing your opponent to either abandon
his position or by backing him into a
corner where he has to work where he has
to defend some kind of irrational
indefensible proposition in order to
maintain his position
that's another way to internet and once
that happens in the argument the
argument is over you won even if it
continues you've still won it's over so
let's
through the process when I say boys
shouldn't race against curls and you say
yes they should and I say no they
shouldn't because boys are biologically
different from girls and you say either
no they aren't different or the
differences don't matter well at that
point I've won
with your last statement there you have
just said something irrational and
indefensible and wrong and so I've won
checkmate in two moves that's all that's
the end there's nothing more that can be
said you just claimed either that boys
and girls are the same or that their
differences aren't relevant to something
like track and field and either of those
positions are completely lacking in
anything resembling reason coherence
logic or scientific accuracy and so
therefore the argument is over now I'm
emphasizing this point for a reason
because it's important for us to
understand
that um that there is no way for us to
win the argument after it's already been
won
and the people who've been defeated just
simply refused to acknowledge that
they've been defeated
because at that point it's not really an
argument anymore
and when it comes to something like
transgenderism particularly the issue of
should boys be allowed in the girls
restroom should boys be allowed to race
against girls and so on the people who
believe in this stuff they believe in it
based on a religious faith it is a
superstition for them they have not
reasoned their way to this position
so you can't reason them out of it
either
they haven't looked at the physical
evidence and said to themself well yes I
mean logically clearly a boy just like a
girl then there's no difference and so
they should race against each other you
know that's not the process that's
happened they have just accepted this as
a matter of faith as a matter of
ideology you know might also be kind of
an ideological expediency because they
you know they realized that by
supporting this transgender stuff they
ideologically it benefits them in some
way but either way
this is not logical for them
and so for those of us who oppose this
and who recognize that it's just wrong
and baseless
well the main thing we can do and should
do
is simply put our foot down and resist
it give it no room seed nothing to it at
all
that's what we need to do we've already
won the argument it's an easy argument
to win it's just
scientifically these are different types
of people
boy girl they're not the same okay
that's it argument is one right there
I've wanted so that that that's that
part of the of the program is over the
argument part is over it's one okay they
still won't accept it because they have
this this is a religious faith
superstition for okay so now our next
move is just whatever they try to do
next resist it oppose it do not allow it
period that's what we have to do what
does that mean in the case of boys
racing against girls it means that the
parents of the girls the girls who are
the victims here the parents need to
band together not to make arguments not
to sign petitions not know they need to
band together and refuse to participate
in this kind of thing they need to say
no this isn't going to happen we will
not accept this we're gonna pull our our
daughters out of track out of the meets
until this boy is kicked out they are so
you know what you want to have a boy
race we're gonna pull our girls out let
them run around the track by himself
okay let them do that let let this track
meet just devolve into total and
coherence because we are not going to
participate
why isn't that happening I just want out
we stink in these situations where are
the parents what are you doing why are
you why are you having your daughter
participate in this theater why are you
having her humiliate herself by by
racing against this boy that she clearly
cannot beat for through no fault of her
own and so now she has to go through the
the humiliation of losing to someone
who's cheating
these boys are openly cheating
you know it would be like if it was if
you're if you're racing in a you know
your your daughters are lining up for a
for a race and then a girl rolls up on a
on a motorcycle and the people in charge
of the race say yeah well we're gonna
let her have a motor skills can have one
but she can have one
well would you tell your daughter to go
ahead and race anyways chris dodd's
that's not even a race anymore this is
why I don't know what this is but it's
not no I'm not gonna participate in this
that's what every parent should say
every parent should absolutely refuse to
have their daughters enrolled in these
sports so long as this charade is going
on and if that were to happen then the
schools would be forced to make a choice
they'd have to choose between
effectively abolishing girls sports or
kicking the boys out
that's the choice they can make
the parents the choice of the parents
are giving the school is give us back
our girl sports with just girls or we
will not enroll our girls in this
monstrosity that you have created this I
don't even know it can't even call girls
sports anymore this this theatre this
charade we're not going to roll our
girls net and so we will blame you
rightly so for depriving us of girls
sports
so you can appease the one or two
confused boys in the school and honestly
I'm not even sure that they are confused
especially this guy who raced against
the boys a couple months ago and is now
a girl I simply don't believe that he's
even confused about who he is I don't
believe it I think he's just plain old
cheating
and we need to be able to call it what
it is because that's what a lot of this
stuff is
now III fully believe that there's a
certain number of so-called transgenders
who are legitimately mentally ill which
isn't to say that they're legitimately
you know the transgenderism itself is
not a legitimate phenomenon
scientifically or medically but they
obviously have some issues and so we
should be compassionate to them and and
I have a lot of pity for them and I pray
for them
but we still should not
seed to their demands and we should not
participate in their delusions or
enforce them that's the worst thing we
could do for them but that's one
category okay I think these days
especially you also have another
category of people who are quote
transgender especially when it comes to
these boys that are competing us girls
what I just I don't believe that they're
even confused I think that they're just
cheated they're just pretending plans
them I have quite a bit less pity
so anyway the schools can choose between
appeasing these confused boys and these
cheating boys
they can appease them
and thus alienate every girl and every
parent in the school
or they can do the opposite
that's the choice that the schools have
to be given
like who are you going to alienate these
one or two boys
to cheat or are you gonna alienate every
girl in the school and actually it's not
even alienating to tell a boy that he
can't compete against girls
you're not alienating him to be
alienated is to be is to be excluded
from some group that you ought to be a
part of that's what it means to be alien
it it to be alienated is to be deprived
of something of your rightful place in a
you know somewhere so boys who are told
that they can't compete against girls or
who are told they can't go in the girls
restroom what-have-you they are not
being alienated they're being the
opposite of alienated they're being told
no we're going to include you where you
belong which is with the boys it's the
girls who are being alienated when you
allow boys to compete against them
because they are being deprived of
having that exclusive girls competition
which is what they should have so
they're the ones being alienated
the only way
that this stuff you know this gender
identity transgenderism all the stuff
the only way that this stuff has been
able to proliferate
is because people who know better people
who are rational people who are in the
majority have been silent and compliant
and obedient and I've just let it happen
and so we've got to stop letting it
happen
and I just think this issue with the
sports is a perfect example these
parents like all you need to have is a
little bit of courage just a little bit
just a little tiny symbol full of
courage that's all we need in our
society right now
there's a lot of there are a lot of lies
that we all know our lives and yet have
been able to to grab hold of our culture
because we most of us we don't possess
even the smallest little smidgen of
courage to stand up and say anything
about it
that's really the great crisis in
American society is cowardice we're just
a nation of absolute cowards who will
who will just won't say anything will
let refused to make any kind of stand
whatsoever if we all had just the
smallest tiniest little bit of courage
then things would change overnight and
that's all that's required to stand up
against this transgenderism stuff it's
just especially in this context of
sports and so on it just requires the
smallest amount of courage because with
everybody if you stand up and say
something almost everybody is going to
agree with you now they may agree
silently in their heads because they're
cowards but they will agree with you
you're only going to have to deal with a
backlash from a small smattering of LGBT
extremists and who cares what they say
cares what they think
gars
so a little bit of courage is all that's
needed in these times
try that on for size and see what a what
a difference it makes thanks for
watching everybody thanks for listening
Godspeed